Keine Frage: Die Anti-Baby-Pille ist bisher
reine Frauensache...
Doch das das soll sich ändern und so forschen
Fachleute schon seit Jahren an der “Pille
für den Mann”.
Ein Forschungsteam aus den USA meldet jetzt
einen Durchbruch.
Die Experten und Expertinnen haben ein Mittel
vorgestellt, das die Produktion der Spermien
vorübergehend stoppt und nur wenige Nebenwirkungen
mit sich bringen soll.
Kommt dieses Mittel also tatsächlich als
sicheres Verhütungsmittel in Frage?
Und wann können wir es nutzen?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Eine wirkliche Alternative zum Kondom haben
wir Männer nicht.
Und ein sicheres und wirksames Verhütungsmittel
für den Mann zu finden, ist alles anders
als einfach.
Forschungsteams weltweit forschen schon seit
Jahren mit Hochdruck daran.
Sie verfolgen viele verschiedene Ansätze,
die von spermien-schädigenden Gels bis hin
zum Samenleiter-Ventil reichen.
Aber natürlich wäre auch eine sichere und
wirksame Hormon-Methode wünschenswert.
Und zwar im besten Fall eine, die keine oder
nur sehr wenige Nebenwirkungen mit sich bringt.
Doch um eine hormonelle Verhütung für den
Mann zu entwickeln, muss eine riesige Herausforderung
bewältigt werden.
Und zwar lässt sich der männliche Körper
in dieser Hinsicht nicht so einfach austricksen
wie es beim weiblichen Körper der Fall ist.
Denn die Anti-Baby-Pille täuscht diesem ja
vor, schwanger zu sein.
So kann der Eisprung gestoppt werden - und
zwar mit einer relativ niedrigen Hormondosis.
Bei Männern dagegen gibt es keine natürliche
Phase, in der er unfruchtbar ist.
Das bedeutet, dass hohe Mengen an Hormonen
notwendig sind, um die Bildung von Samenzellen
zuverlässig zu verhindern.
Und so zeigte sich bei den bisherigen Wirkstoffen,
die für die hormonelle männliche Empfängnisverhütung
entwickelt worden waren, viele unerwünschte
Nebenwirkungen.
Und so lautet das erklärte Ziel, das effizienteste
Mittel mit den geringsten Nebenwirkungen zu
finden.
Im Klartext: Der Wirkstoff muss die Spermaproduktion
stoppen, darf dabei aber keinesfalls die männliche
Libido, also die Lust, hemmen.
Das hätte dann ja auch nicht so viel Sinn.
Die Ergebnisse eines US-Forschungsteams geben
jetzt neue Hoffnung.
Der Wirkstoff namens 11-Beta-Methyl-19-Nortestosteron-Dodekylcarbonat,
oder abgekürzt 11-Beta-MNTDC, soll die
körpereigene Produktion von Testosteron in
den Hoden stoppen.
Dabei handelt es sich um das wichtigste männliche
Sexualhormon.
So wird dann letztendlich auch die Produktion
der Spermien gestoppt.
Dazu Christina Wang, die an der Studie beteiligt
war: “Unsere Ergebnisse zeigen, dass diese
Pille (..) die Spermienproduktion reduziert,
aber die Libido aufrecht hält.“ 40 gesunde
Männer zwischen 18 und 50 Jahren hatten an
der Studie teilgenommen. 30 von ihnen hatten
tatsächlich die neu entwickelte Pille für
den Mann eingenommen; die anderen zehn Teilnehmer
dagegen erhielten ein Placebo.
Der Test lief 28 Tage lang und das Ergebnis
ist tatsächlich vielversprechend.
Denn, auch wenn einige Männer unter Gewichtszunahme
und leichten Kopfschmerzen klagten, wirkt
die Pille!
Leichte Nebenwirkungen wie Müdigkeit oder
Akne gab es nur bei wenigen Männern.
Doch der Test zeigte auch, dass einige Tester
an Potenzproblemen litten.
Zwei Männer litten unter einer leichten erektilen
Dysfunktion, also einer Erektionsstörung.
Fünf Teilnehmer gaben an, dass ihr Sexualtrieb
durch die Pille leicht abgenommen hatte.
Dennoch ist das US-Forschungsteam optimistisch,
bald einen Durchbruch zu erzielen.
Schon in zehn Jahren könnte demnach ein hormonelles
Mittel zur Empfängnisverhütung für Männer
auf den Markt kommen.
Dazu Stephanie Page von der University of
Washington in Seattle: “Wir arbeiten parallel
an zwei oralen Verhütungsmitteln, um das
Feld der Verhütungs-Medizin voranzubringen
und den besten Wirkstoff zu finden“.
Fest steht, dass das neu entwickelte Mittel
vor einer möglichen Marktzulassung noch viele
langwierige Prozesse durchlaufen muss.
Das ist bei der Zulassung von Medikamenten
so üblich.
So wurde das Mittel bisher lediglich in einer
sogenannten “Phase I-Studie” getestet,
bei der nur wenige Probanden teilnehmen.
Erst danach folgen umfangreichere Tests.
Diese “Phase II-” und “Phase III-Studien”
laufen dann aber meistens über viele Jahre.
Erst, wenn diese Studien erfolgreich sind,
darf das Präparat zugelassen werden.
Und so lässt die Alternative zum Kondom erst
einmal noch auf sich warten.
Und noch bei einem anderen Thema spielt die
Chemie in unserem Körper eine große Rolle:
Neue Epidemie: Einsamkeit!
Das macht sie mit unserem Körper.
Draufklicken, anschauen und natürlich Clixoom
Science & Fiction abonnieren, wenn ihr es
noch nicht gemacht habt.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!